okay everybody so I have the great honor
of being able to be joined by Piercy
Dalton aka Naomi from the open house on
Netflix Piercy how are you today
I'm doing great thank you I'm really
excited actually oh that's awesome I I'm
really excited to talk to you and what's
funny as I just watched the movie I woke
up early to watch it was probably the
first time I'd watched a horror movie at
7:00 in the morning crazy experience but
I really enjoyed it you know awesome in
it but before we get to the movie I want
to know a little bit about you and right
off the bat I think you're the first
Piercy I've ever talked to it's a
magical first name where did it come
from
um it's my mother's maiden name actually
oh yeah and it's not my given first name
it's a middle name that I have that she
gave to all of like me and my siblings
actually my first name is Susan there
was another season Dalton in the Union
here in Canada and so there was a
conflict if I ever wanted to join the
Union actually I hadn't tried even if I
wanted to join the Union there would be
a conflict so friend of mine advised me
to change my name and I ended up I mean
I kind of always wanted to change it
anyways to be honest and I talked to my
mom and asked if I could use PSE I
talked to my siblings outside Cadiz
Piercy and now I represent both my
mother and my father
equally that's really cool you didn't
have to fight with your siblings over it
to get fair see were they like hey wait
a minute I might do that like yeah it
was easy transition now you have
Canadian American dual citizenship you
were born in Arizona and then you were
raised in Ontario what was that drastic
move like I mean do you remember any
time and I was only like how old are you
moved to Canada and was there any reason
for that yeah I was my dad was studying
down in the States oh my both my parents
were born in Canada and he was doing his
PhD at University of Arizona and so I
was born during that and I moved when I
was one I have some memories in Arizona
that I didn't realize we're in Arizona
I barely remember it but we go back
often now do you currently reside in
Canada now or did you move back to the
States
now I reside in Los Angeles where did
that choice go from like why did you
want to leave Canada now and go and move
to LA I have to admit that it was the
warmer weather
I moved so I was raised in Ontario in
the snow and I went to school there and
then eventually well I found a school in
physical theater actually in Vancouver
and I had become interested in physical
theater so it was the only School in
North America so I checked it out and I
had been tree planting out west actually
for many years so I knew that it was a
beautiful beautiful province and then I
thought I'll just go to school there and
seeing how the part of Canada and then I
thought once I got here that the weather
was so beautiful that I would never have
to leave again and then after about 8
years I started feeling cold during the
winters and the rain was getting too
much for me so I thought oh yeah I can
keep moving south because I have dual
citizenship and then I can be warmer
yeah I had also met an acting coach up
here that I really loved working with so
I I had wanted to move down a bit
earlier but then I stayed with her to
train for a while then I moved down
after a few years of training now when
did you know you wanted to be an actress
forever I think probably Mary Poppins
was one of my first inspiration I just
loved the magic of it of her you know
laughing herself with feeling pulling
everything out of her bag and it all
just expanded my imagination while I
watched that movie and I I think I got
hooked but then I I don't think I
actually started performing until junior
high was there any actress that you
specifically looked up to or it was like
okay I want to be like that yeah not
really actually until I started training
and our acting coach was incredible it
helping us kind of set goals or be
confident enough to choose someone to
look up to you know and yeah start
shaping your own craft so there are some
strong actors that I look up but you
know it also always changes sure I think
yeah definitely before we jump into the
movie I just want to warn my
sinners that spoilers ahead if you
haven't seen the open house yet watch
that first and then come back to this
interview but we're gonna talk about
spoilers in it so yeah this is your
warning so my question to you is how did
this role come about and what was your
addition process like well I knew I met
Matt and Suzanne the directors at my
acting studio in Vancouver Matt is also
an actor and he and I worked on a scene
together and Suzanne was in town with
him at one time and came and watched and
so she knew my acting at least a little
bit I got to know them because I had
just moved to Los Angeles and that's
where they live but Matt comes up to
Train sometimes in Vancouver so when we
all went back to Los Angeles we started
to hang out just from having formed a
friendship and then they were talking to
me about this movie and I thought it was
actually all cast and ready to go but I
think they made a change along the way
they decided to do it as an indie I
think originally they had figure
production in the work you know with
bigger names and our big names was
burned then they worked on a feature
that our acting coach did and her and
her partner did it pretty much just the
two of them arranged everything there
was a very minimal crew and Matt Suzanne
was so inspired by the work Matt was the
lead in that movie and he was so
inspired by what they pulled off that
him and Suzanne just decided they would
do the same so at that point everything
was in their hands suddenly they had
control of casting and everything so
they reached out to me and asked me to
audition which I was very surprised
because I just thought it was already up
and running and I did and then they cast
me that's a menu got casted and you got
the role did you know at that point it
was a Netflix Project yet no no not at
all no we hadn't yeah we didn't know at
all it was really like everyone came
together like everybody and this whole
project came together and really worked
so hard it was one of those situations
where we were all making it work you
know and because we loved it and because
we loved Matt and Suzanne and we and it
felt like a family kind of thing sure we
all come together and just pull it off
you know it was their first movie that
was exciting I
never been in a feature that was
exciting yeah and so we were all
learning and and having fun with the
fact that it was a thriller you know it
was kind of creepy to be honest early
set for that long in a good way
yeah when when did you find out you were
gonna be with Dylan Manette the breakout
star from 13 reasons why life how did
that come about well that was
interesting because he wasn't the
breakout star from 13 reasons why when
we shot it okay yeah he had actually
just finished shooting season one when
he came to shoot the open house and so
he managed and know him from Los Angeles
and we were all kind of we're all kind
of just getting this movie timing
because it was cool you know house we
were like yeah let's let's get a movie
done for Matt and Suzanne and have fun
whatever and I think yeah it wasn't for
a while after that I can't remember how
long after that 13 reasons came out and
then it was like kind of a game changer
interesting so now did you and Dylan
rehearse all the scenes prior offset or
do you just kind of go for it when you
guys are on set with it we had a bit of
both there wasn't a ton of rehearsal
because Dylan had just jumped from one
project to this one but we we would work
with Matt and Suzanne definitely before
we got to set but Dylan's a pro and
definitely knew what he was doing on set
and helped me really probably that way
like I'm I'm trained more in a theater
style of acting and so I'm used to a lot
of rehearsal and a lot of work with my
scene partner kind of thing so Dylan
really actually showed me when you're on
set and it's a much faster pace and you
know sometimes you do one scene that
wasn't planned because you had to move
things around or whatever and he really
helped me get through those and show me
how it's done kind of thing that's
amazing if that's really cool you get
the opportunity and you're learning at
the same time and I was gonna ask - for
the character of Naomi how did you get
into that mindset of her was there
anything in your personal life that came
to mind anywhere you got aspirations
from like you have children of your own
I don't have my own children I have I do
have nephew than I I feel like probably
every one of my friends from growing up
now has children so I'm used to them but
yeah I did have personal things to pull
on and that's how I trained as an actor
and our acting coach Kate raw in
Vancouver is incredible at helping us
use the things in our life - you know
shape our craft and share with others
and be able to relate to our characters
and so that audiences can relate to our
characters and we can represent you know
many other people besides just ourselves
and I guess it's a mix it's definitely a
mix of like given circumstance plus
something I've been through and sitting
with Matt and Suzanne and understanding
exactly the driving force because the
Dare thriller isn't just
genre film you know like they really
wanted it to be real and they really
wanted it to be drawn from real-life
circumstances that people find
themselves in specifically - grief is
such a difficult emotion to deal with
and something to go through that we all
I find everyone deals with it
differently and it can get out of hand
you know so they wanted to respect that
and you know even though it's a thriller
and can get sure heightens you know they
really wanted to keep that aspect of it
very real city life like when someone is
breathing you can be lost and you can
reach out in funny ways or react in some
you know ways that maybe aren't the most
helpful at the time and so I think they
kept me just really grounded in myself
and how I would they really kept me
focused on the death of my husband right
so more than anything else and that that
can be you know such a heavy role
playing a widow and it is a very dark
movie did you feel that weight carry a
bit offset at all in like your life or
deep can you like turn a switch on and
off you're like okay I'm not on set back
to being period yeah how does that go
about yeah I do carry it and I but I've
learned to do that in a really healthy
way it never takes over but I carry it
actually in order to fully embody it so
that I can fully embody it to the best I
can you know well you don't go full
method like do they look like you're not
sitting in your house like it's somewhat
in my house yeah no I don't but actually
to that point I did sleep on in the main
like this massive beautiful home that we
were shooting in in Big Bear I did sleep
in the house
Wow most of the shoot yeah actually yeah
it's interesting I shot I slept in one
of the rooms that we ended up shooting
and I couldn't sleep in it again I am
superstitious like I was pretty open to
receiving creepy little messages from
the spirits or something well I went
there you know like lights went out on
me while I was in the shower I woke up
with like a few little scratches on my
arm one morning stuff like that hello
yeah so I played with it you know like
sure I accepted it but I didn't let it
rule that's my severe oh yeah
it was pretty fun had you ever seen
yourself doing har had you done any hard
like films before no I definitely hadn't
imagined doing horror and I guess I've
done a couple of short films but leaning
towards a darker five I guess atmosphere
especially because in Vancouver actually
there's there's a thing called blood
shots and it's a short film competition
it during Halloween so it's all scary
movies you know and then it's just like
Vancouver is amazing for getting people
up in making little movies like they
have a few different competitions in
town and they really celebrate it so I
had done a couple of things like that
just for blood shots whatever but I
hadn't imagined doing it in a feature at
all or let alone my shirt my first lead
in a feature yeah that's it that's a
huge inch score and land and that's
really fresh yeah and I was asked to do
you have like a specific do you have a
favorite horror film we're just one that
you really could just pop your head and
think of that you really love that kind
of guy you may be excited for this oh
man well yeah I mean they talked about
The Shining they gave me some other
references to watch you know I think
this shining is the ultimate for me
because because you don't really know
what's going on ever and I think I think
that mysterious feeling to feel you know
and and because it was still like such a
great job with real-life humans like you
know you believe in these humans and you
believe they could exist in that yeah
and I said world I think this movie
really was effective with that too that
it was playing on that fear of like
the hell is going on like I was watching
the whole time I was just in sheer
terror of like you don't know what is
really happening and he gave a moment I
thought you played that really well and
everyone on set did a great job doing
that what if that was really interesting
about this story with Naomi was we meet
her husband's beginning and then he gets
hit by a car pretty quickly buddy to me
he felt very mysterious as an actors
when you're playing Naomi do you because
we as the audience we don't know much
about the husband at all so did you feel
like going to create a backstory in your
head for him as play Naomi or do you
kind of just like let it be uh no III
definitely created backstories and
actually an Abrams who's played my
husband was really cool to hang out with
on set too so we were able to yeah I
said because we had to get together you
know to beforehand a couple of times and
so we even created a lot together which
is always helpful so you do feel a
little part there to do I do for me
okay for me yeah I know that I think I
do see that other people work
differently and and that works for them
but for me I do I need to endow and
pretty much everything in the script I
was asked to you mentioned now that Matt
and Suzanne are the two directors what
is like working with two directors
because are they both on set for each
scene or they're like oh he's doing one
day she's doing the other I was imagine
like there's arguing or something what
is that like yeah you know that's really
cool because madam Suzanne are engaged
oh you know yeah okay so their partners
in life and they decide to do this movie
together and I so I definitely expected
I was like things might get weird you
know if they're having an argument but
you were so impressive I still can't
believe it they each they each come from
very like kind of different perspectives
who then studied a lot in film and not
has learned from kind of growing up
around part of the production side of
things and he's really interested I'm
very smart
like he picks it up really well and they
both were 100% on the same page about
how the movie was going to go
no matter what was like there was
definitely trying times I mean we shot
like it's very fast we had no money you
know you knew we had no money we were
all we all had a hand in everything kind
of thing at some point so that can cause
a lot of stress no matter what was going
on they were together all the time and
sometimes
location-wise would have them like for
example we were shooting in the car and
only one of them could fit in the car Oh
God so they they took turns on different
takes or like one would sit there when
it when it was on Dylan want to sit
there what it was on me or something
like that or one would always be on the
walkie-talkie and they would take turns
also with directing a certain scene but
then if there was ever something that
wasn't working or something that needed
to be shifted they would just consult
each other and then come back with their
with their next move like it was all I
was just blown away by it really they
knew exactly what they wanted they stuck
to it no matter what and they always
worked together very well oh wow that's
that is super interesting up now this
has to be a dream come true for you I'm
assuming was it an amazing feeling
seeing your face pop up right on the
Netflix menu because that's what I saw
your face right when I opened it I'm
like wow for you that has to be crazy it
was pretty crazy is a really good word
for it it feels it's definitely a bit
bizarre because really there's a part of
me that doesn't think anything has
changed you know to have it finally on
Netflix we shot it over a year ago it's
such a bizarre feeling cuz you've
already done the work you know and then
now something is happening with it that
definitely everyone around me is so
excited and that feels incredible and
it's really nice to finally have some
work of mine able to be seen by friends
and family at ease you know instead of
like having them run to film festivals
or sending links or you know getting
them to watch it a specific time in a
specific day like it it is definitely an
incredible opportunity are you like okay
with watching yourself they know some
actresses actors feel a little weird
about it
can you watch yourself and be okay with
it no what I do it to say this movie is
a little different because it scares the
crap out of me sure and I thought like I
and expect that because I know it so
well but it still scares me and it even
moved me a little bit when I watched it
before I left la they held a private
screening for us so I got to see it all
completed and done and it was easier
than it's been for me in the past I
think because I was way more focused on
staying in my seat not screaming you
know and then watching my acting but it
is kind of hard to watch it though sure
I noticed too you have very iconic curly
hair and I think it's refreshing to see
that I don't want to ask do you live and
die by the curly hair like would you
refuse to do a straight hair role that's
a great question and now that you've
asked that I kind of wish that I had
chosen that but I don't I I might do
that now I might live and die by the
gray yeah no yeah I know I will do
straight here for sure but I think you
know what's funny I always thought that
the curly hair would maybe be a problem
because it stands out so much so I
always offer to straighten it but so far
most directors prefer that I keep the
curly hair so yeah that's great here for
me that it stands out like I don't know
I done for me I like always seeing like
something that gives a new edge to it
and I feel like that is a cool thing
about you I know that's such a random
thing to say but these little things I
notice now that's a great thing to say I
loved hearing okay yeah now okay for the
fans who watch this movie I thought the
ending was a little open-ended and my
take was it you know could hint a little
bit of a sequel do you think if there
was is there any chance your character
might be alive I know she got stabbed
but I feel like there might be a chance
have you thought about there I hadn't
until this family and friends screaming
we had and someone in the audience came
up to me and said you survived to that
like and because he talked about the
previous torture scene right and he's
like if you survived that you know and
and like and you did it for your child
he was just like you got a stab wound
that was all like you're getting up and
out of there so I had I'd never
considered it but I'm down for it yeah
hell yeah that would be amazing
yeah Piercy I want to thank you so much
for joining me today
honor to talk to you and I'm super
grateful everyone please check out the
open house on Netflix and watch already
and Pierce is there anything else you'd
like to promote before I say goodbye no
good watch the open house yeah thank you
for watching yeah oh thank you again
thank you so much for coming on everyone
you must check it out it's on Netflix
there's no excuse not to watch it and
yeah it's a great date movie too for
anything scary want to watch and hear
sea kills it so I'm excited for your
future and acting as well and what else
you're gonna bring to us oh thank you
thank you so much that really appreciate